meine sachen und herz bekommen zu einem
neuen video ich begrüße euch zu einer
neuen episode von wie viele gehirnzellen
kann ein mensch in zehn minuten
verlieren nachdem sich mein letztes
video ausnahmsweise mal meine normalen
inhalt gedreht hat kann ich es verstehen
dass ihr zutiefst gekränkt und beleidigt
sein und dass ihr das dringende
bedürfnis haben die paar restlichen
gehirnzellen die euch nach dem schauen
meine videos noch verblieben sind nun
endgültig zu vernichten kann das geläut
ich kann mich beruhigen
ich habe genau das richtige video dafür
ist wir sind mittlerweile ja quasi schon
richtige hilfe experten leute und wir
wissen es gibt so folgen die natürlich
auch absurd sind und die auch irgendwie
scheiße sind aber die auf der menschlich
gesehen ziemlich abstoßend skala jetzt
nicht ganz das maximum erreichen dieses
video was wir es heute anfangen werden
ist ganz darum gebe ich aber den titel
tochter und mutter schwanger vom selben
man ja ganz kurz bevor es losgeht ist
das denn aus der zukunft vom ende des
videos ich habe schon gesehen was in
diesem video passiert und ich muss sich
vor waren dass hier was sie gleich sehen
wir das ist wirklich als edv für hart
gesottene wenn euch die funktion einer
gehirnzellen wichtig ist dann weiß nicht
sollte man dieses video vielleicht nicht
anschauen aber für alle anderen die sich
davon verabschiedet haben viel spaß
[Musik]
das video sechs sekunden alt und aus
irgendeinem unerfindlichen grund hat es
das rtl2 team für eine gute idee
gehalten an diesem punkt schon an dem
punkt der schweren sexuellen belästigung
anzukommen und an dem punkt anzukommen
wo ein schätzungsweise 45 jähriger sich
von der couch rollt perfekt aja leute
ihr merkt schon und ich versuche gerade
zu sprechen aber aufgrund akuten gehen
schon jetzt bin ich bereit dazu nicht
mehr in der lage ist neben ernst heute
versuchen wir zu ergründen was ihr
passiert also wir haben hier die wahl
dieses mädchen und ihre mutter um dieses
video geht und irgendeinen da ist
einfach irgend so ein typ mit
pferdeschwanz in der wohnung und er hat
sich eben kurz auf ihre mutter getötet
sonst geht's noch
man muss sagen dass natürlich auch mehr
alltägliche situationen man kommt mal
wieder nach hause und schon wieder ist
es soweit dass eine vollkommen fremde
personen auf einem eigenen elternteil
sitzt ich meine wir sind alle schon mal
ein punkt gewesen dementsprechend rtl2
und hilf mir vielen dank nochmal dafür
dass ihr diesen ratgeber uns allen
zugänglich macht was geht hier ab habe
ich das jetzt richtig verstanden sich
auf einer seite angemeldet wo es darum
geht gemeinsam kinder zu zeugen das
stand der sinn der sache zu sein coupé
rating also gemeinsam eltern sein und
sie erzählt irgendwas von künstliche
befruchtung okay perfekt also sie hat
sich einfach quasi für so ein elite
partner fürs kinderkriegen angemeldet
und überraschung auf seiner seite sind
geisteskranke person hätte das gedacht
ja okay gut an der stelle muss man sagen
das ist ein problem was man über
nachvollziehen kann wenn die kinder von
eltern ausziehen um zu studieren ins
ausland zu gehen und eine ausbildung zu
machen woanders whatever dann ist es
erstmal eine ungewohnte situation für
die eltern und es fehlt so ein bisschen
der lebensinhalt
das heißt im umkehrschluss aber nicht
dass man sich über das internet einen
fremden versuchen sollte um mit dem
einfach ein kind in die welt zu setzen
das sollte jetzt nicht die erste
reaktion auf die sache sein
leute korrigiert mich wenn ich die ganze
sache jetzt verstehe aber ihre mutter
hat sich jetzt über den wunsch gehabt
über das internet einen typen kennen zu
lernen um mit dem ein kind in die welt
zu setzen weil ihr sonst langweilig ist
wenn ihre tochter auszieht ihre tochter
daraufhin so mama du bist verrückt aber
übrigens der vater von meiner freundin
der finde ich ganz gut zeugt davon mit
dem kind menschlich gesehen ziemlich
abstoßend
okay leute das wahlvolk an der stelle
was ist das für ein umgang mit dem thema
familie gründen
das ist so borde game ist übels
langweilig ich glaube ich auch ein kind
okay was passiert jetzt ich hab nichts
raus geschnitten leute es ist einfach
die nächste szene ist schon wieder typ
zu besuch in scheinbar schlechte
erfahrung gemacht mit dem letzten typen
denen sie unbekannt eingeladen hat laden
wir erst mal direkt den nächsten ein
monte was sagen wir dazu nicht unbedingt
die klügste entscheidung
worum geht's jetzt sagen bitte dass es
jetzt nicht darum geht dass sie jetzt
mit dem einfach ein kind in die welt
setzen will und wie ich einfach machen
kaufen
mal ein bisschen locker heute ist ein
supertag dafür ich spüre dass und je
schneller desto besser ich wäre ja auch
nicht
also leute wirklich ich weiß nicht was
ich sagen soll ich glaube mir ihr wisst
ja leute ich hab ja schon wirklich
einige hilfen folgen gesehen wer muss
schon einige hilfen folgen zusammen
angeschaut aber was zum ist das hier so
was sollte eigentlich nicht existieren
und die ist jetzt auch noch keine 60
also das ist genau der richtige
das wird schlafen leute ist das klein
das geht nicht es geht mir nicht in den
kopf rein sie hat jetzt nicht allen
ernstes anhand eines telefonats
entschieden dass der potenziell ein
guter vater für das kind ist was sie
dringend braucht weile langweilig ist
sagt mir dass es nicht so ist er ohne
wirtsleute ich weiß ich sag das öfter
aber diesmal ist es wirklich nicht
übertrieben das ist doch das ist
scheinbar wirklich die story so wie es
gerade eben beschrieben habe rtl 2 hat
sich dieses hobby so ausgedacht also
ganz im ernst leute diese folge das geht
einfach nicht klar
das ist nicht nur gehirnzellen verlust
weil es einfach dumm ist es auch
seelischer schmerz also ich habe das
gefühl ich bin von dieser folge
traumatisiert ich glaube es wird zeit
dass wir einen verein für hilfen der
geschädigte gründen machen sie jetzt
einfach
[Musik]
diese beiden menschen gehen einfach mit
dem thema kinderkriegen familie planen
so als würden sie sich keine ahnung
neuen kugelschreiber anschaffen menschen
abstoßend aber ich glaube jetzt garten
anruf das ist natürlich dann auch in dem
fall wichtiger als sich mal die täter
mit auseinanderzusetzen
wer jetzt der vater des eigenen kindes
wird kann ich gut verstehen
auch dass leute ist eine situation die
wir alle nur zu gut kennen man kommt
nach hause und die eigene mutter da ich
das kann man nicht mal sagen was ich
sagen will ist man kommt nach hause und
die eigene mutter hat selbstverständlich
wieder mal einen völlig fremden mann
eingeladen um dann mit diesem mann mit
dem sie noch nicht mal die kaffee
getrunken hat auch mal die künstliche
befruchtung einzuleiten und nachwuchs zu
zeugen alter wie kann sowas auch wie
kann sowas auf youtube sein ohne scheiß
das kann echt ich seine mitstreiter ich
bin echt schockiert ich bin ich bin
sprachlos tatsächlich
[Musik]
nein leute leute es kann nicht sein
wieso gibt es so was also echt ehrte
jetzt bitte ich meine es wirklich ernst
ihr könnt einfach videos über mobbing
auf baustellen machen oder über leute
die ihre freundinnen meisten aber doch
nicht so was von haas beim leute die da
die mutter kommt einfach so rein okay
ihr wisst worum es geht bei dieser
ganzen sache das haben wir jetzt schon
ich habe erklärt und dann ist sie so zu
ihrer tochter
sorry möchte ich bitte nicht immer eine
angelegenheit nein ich weiß klar jetzt
ist hier ein fremder mann der wohnung
der ist zu dem zwecke hier dass wir
jetzt mal hier die nachwuchsproduktion
reduzieren aber ganz ehrlich ob jetzt
ein geschwisterchen bekommt so könnte
ich hab einfach überhaupt nichts an ich
möchte ich nicht in meinen
angelegenheiten ein stop oder wirtsleute
schreibt mir mal bitte in die kommentare
ob ich übertreibe aber ich finde real
talk ohne übertreibung das ist die
schlimmste hilfe folge die ich jemals
gesehen habe hab ihr habt ihr was die
gerade rausgehauen hat das ist nils ich
habe mit dem noch nicht mehr ein wort
gewechselt
ja mit dem zeug ich jetzt ein kind alles
klar
das war es komplett
[Musik]
das ist schlimm
wie wir uns kennengelernt haben das
können wir nicht so stehen lassen es
sieht ganz so aus als würde sie ihm an
der stelle einfach mal ab problem okay
das sieht aus würde ich sagen aber ganz
ehrlich du bist einfach geisteskrank was
wir jetzt machen heute ist wie es gibt
man einfach mal vor und wir schauen
einfach mal ob sie sich an ihr
versprechen hält 2000 jahre später
eheleute 10 23h panther fans gibt es und
es ist eingetreten was nicht hätte
eintreten sollen der titel dieser folge
scheint wahr zu werden und damit wird
das was am anfang dieser folge passiert
das was an sich schon jenseits jeglichen
menschlichen vorstellungsvermögens lag
noch einmal übertroffen und zwar hier
mit ich werde versuchen möglichst lange
laufen zu lassen ich glaube ich wäre es
nicht lange durchhalten leute
[Musik]
alles klar das was heute die menschheit
ist verloren ganz ehrlich wir müssen uns
keine sorgen haben den globus machen
müssen es keine sorgen mehr machen ich
persönlich finde eine spezies die in der
lage ist so etwas zu produzieren sollte
sich einfach schnellstmöglich von dieser
erde verpissen ich glaube wirklich leute
das war höchste zeit dass wir unsere
therapiegruppe eröffnen wir von dir
einfach erst mal provisorisch hier unten
in den kommentaren schreibt mir gerne
rein was diese folge mit euch gemacht
hat das war so was von mir leute ich
küsse eure augen bis zum nächsten mal